hello welcome to this video she have
2007 that's my opponent so testing a
little bit of one year for Miguel going
for the open society which is always
kind of dicey business for me because
I'm not that knowledgeable yeah okay
shut something something sharp or rather
restrained sharp is more interesting so
maybe you try this age three stuff this
is not always going to be a sharp game
but but here it is
oh that costs lots of time so f4 is
going to go to see for all right
ambitious very ambitious okay but my
position is kind of loose of course
meeting
my main idea he has f5 I'm not sure
that's the right idea but it's my idea
trying to push the f corn forward and if
he moves the e pawn give me the d5
square
it seems that team wants to keep this
option of maybe castling along
if i take here well what is he taking
back with with the Queen prolly let's
still do that Bishop cakes i have root
before that wins the Queen I think luke
t for Quincy five rook a four and the
queen is is is gone yeah yeah I was
thinking we should deform just attacking
g7 and make it difficult for him to
cancel long whoa really okay m so let's
go forward it looks extremely risky
castling short ok so just six
let's try a queen age five and
sacrificing it should be very difficult
to prevent if it takes f5 I play I have
this move so let's see Queen age five
and then take it
it's close to a pre move maybe he has
some some Bishop f5 was stuff like that
I sorry bishop deform after I take yeah
but anyway this is a correctness yeah so
he actually has that hmm it still should
should win let's see I can also check on
his six King moves 93 check
I can also take the six now for Luke d7
should be pretty good as well maybe you
look f6 song
as silk d7 should win can also take the
Queen I mean the number lookup
check check black resigns okay so I've
got got very dangerous quickly I'm
really not sure if this is it could be
too slow and simply so Queen to have
three this long yeah again I'm not I'm
not sure about this decision but I mean
this loses the Queen I think when it is
trapped so that doesn't work so we had
to take with the Queen and now here I
think I know castles really that looked
far too dangerous to me I mean far too
dangerous maybe there is no good
alternative I mean 1g8 Queen h5 looks
bad as well yeah this is looking
terrible I mean really when the engine
is on on +1 on a depth of 22 it this
could be the case where it goes a lot
higher if you give it some time to
calculate this attack looks devastating
here you can argue but this is should
should be enough I think just aiming
further for the kill oh but this is this
immediately was actually stronger yeah
that's true I don't really need this why
didn't it is a winner all the way 97 and
97 wins check oh that's it's cute
actually and now the check check this is
leading to a maid and a couple of
check but ok this is also just win check
oh boo cakes rulebook h7 made all right
mate was pretty good a decade was
already very very comfortable ok guys
thanks for watching